quatre autres et comment tu te sens
épanoui parfaite toute la déco oui mais
prendre du lsd valérie damidot mais ça
veut dire quoi je suis ça veut dire que
là je suis au pied du mur pas et qu'un
jour je serai de l'autre côté
bienvenue dans mon espace intérieur de
vie c'est sûr que ça va je dis pas oui
pourquoi début non sur wii souffle t'as
fumé
oui un petit bisou au nom les petits
trucs pourris la wii mais c'est naturel
oh ça fait gitans ce truc là
oui mais c'est naturel j'aime pas durer
pour se mériter mieux
par contre avec la dépendance affective
point g et orgasme féminin c'est une
réunion à oui tu es sur rampe on est
alors tous les bouquins pour les gens
normaux ils sont passés où je les ai
donné je manquais de place bon en fait
un plein d'état j'ai envie de partout
elles ne sont pas vides elles sont
remplies de l'espace de l'autre c'est
l'espace d'accueil au monde de l'autre
comme ça quand on éternue de travailler
sur moi et que je serai enfin prête à
rencontrer quelqu'un il sentira
instantanément que mon lieu et
bienveillant et que je lis aménager une
sphère dans ma bulle je vous faire des